hey leute was gedacht und herzstück dass
die leute gesagt ich schon zu oft gesagt
noch mal auf neue sale etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut wir
haben uns ein bisschen länger nicht
gesehen ich war eine woche im urlaub
aber jetzt bin ich wieder für euch da
und das paket was für uns heute genauer
anschauen ist eigentlich schon vor dem
urlaub oder vor meinem urlaub
eingetroffen ich habe es nur leider
nicht mehr geschafft das video zu drehen
deswegen machen wir das erst jetzt ist
aber gar kein problem
es wird glaube ich also vor allem für
mich sehr spannend kurz als kleine
vorgeschichte ich wäre auf ebay
unterwegs ein bisschen rum gestöbert und
da war so ein angebot schmuck im wert
von über 1000 euro liegen jedoch drei
stunden es war so eine option wenn ich
euch hier super gerne mal ein
da hat noch niemand darauf geboten und
ich dachte mir kommen weil es nur 105
oder so drauf und hab ich das ding
bekommen ich weiß nicht also ein
bisschen komisch ist es ja schon wenn da
wirklich schmuck im wert von über 1000
euro drin ist warum man das nicht dann
einfach selber verkauft aber wir werden
es heute raus hin und da hinten ist das
paket ich hols mal kurz so sieht das aus
und ich würde sagen wir machen das jetzt
mal auf aber vorher damit ich es nicht
noch mal vergessen haben wir noch das
huawei per smart 2021 kurz der gewinner
kommentar eigenen tut mir leid ich hab's
immer irgendwie vergessen aber
herzlichen glückwunsch sturzes gewonnen
und ich wünsche mir ganz viel spaß damit
und dann bin ich jetzt mal gespannt ob
dieses paket hier ein erfolg wird oder
nicht ich muss sagen schmuck ist jetzt
überhaupt nicht mein spezialgebiet also
ich kann mich ein bisschen mit uhren aus
aber das war's dann auch schon
und deswegen schauen wir einfach mal was
wir hier heute alles haben und natürlich
wird auch ok edel zeit wann das ist
wirklich das erste mal dass wir hier auf
meinem kanal irgendwas mit schmuck
behandeln
juicy couture label das ist das paar
verheiratet mal kurz so hier markenuhren
schmuckwaren wert mehr
1000 euro ovp wundertüte mystery sandbox
neu ok abgesetzter titel auf jeden fall
ihr könnt hier sehen uci couture das
mache ich mal vorsichtig auf und wir
schauen aber was hier drin ist also das
sieht wirklich so aus als wäre das
bisher
eine uhr heute schaut mal her wir haben
hier eine rolle die sieht muss ich sagen
ich würde erstmal schätzen ist eine
damenuhr die sieht aber geil aus und das
interessante ist die geht sogar richtig
wir haben gerade 17 27 also geil die
marke sagt mir jetzt nichts himmel steht
drauf christoph fromm barofsky da muss
ich jetzt mal kurz den preis ergoogeln
weil das ist ja irgendwie das wichtigste
für mich der wtf nähe oder das ist ja
nicht diese marke das ist nach dieser
tik tok trend wo alle diese hose an
haben worauf ihr marsch und uci steht
aber das ist was anderes oder weil hier
wird das gerade mir angezeigt ach ich
hab die uhr gefunden liegt zwischen 80
bis 100 5 euro plus steuern ja würde ich
erst mal sagen ein guter start für das
erste produkt ich meine ich habe
insgesamt 145 euro bezahlt wenn ich die
400 weltkriege hat sich ja schon fast
gelohnt also machen wir mal weiter ich
glaube da sind noch bessere sachen sind
okay hier haben wir tatsächlich von
haribo drauf haribo wie sie das ist das
ist dass eine band oder so was also wir
haben ja tatsächlich so ein kleines
armband mit einem gummibärchen dran habe
ich vorher so noch nie gesehen würde ich
jetzt persönlich auch nicht tragen aber
weiß nicht an sich ganz nett aber ich
glaube das ist jetzt leider nicht so
viel wert ich habe das jetzt ungefähr so
ähnlich gefunden für 20 euro legen wir
mal schnell zur seite
weiter gehts hier haben wir nochmal
einen armreifen oder hat ist das können
wir hier für die mädels kannst du hier
auf klicken oder meinetwegen natürlich
auch für jungs wer's mag geht nicht auf
der scheiß also esprit 8 mio guck mal
sogar als wenn das von esprit ich hoffe
wir können sehen 99 euro 90 steht daran
also das glaube ich im leben nicht da
also hierfür würde ich nicht mal einen
euro bezahlen das hat wahrscheinlich der
verkäufer der manuell irgendwie drauf
geklebt damit das so aussieht als wäre
das teuer und er dann 1000 euro
warenwert angeben kann
also es gibt wirklich so esfri armbänder
für 69 euro 70 eur 85 euro keine ahnung
also ich weiss crack ich würde niemals
so viel geld dafür ausgeben aber wenn
das mal 99 euro 90 gekostet hat dann
glaube ich dass jetzt erst mal so machen
wir weiter mit irgendwas was ganz cool
aussieht das hier ist von der marke
skaten oder skagen aus dänemark dänemark
das hört sich schon mal gut an ist immer
teuer und die haben wir auch eine uhr
erinnert mich ein bisschen vielleicht an
diese daniel wellington instagram
watches könnte auch so eine typische
marke seien mit der irgendwelche 08 15
influenza in deutschland
zusammenarbeiten wie zum beispiel auch
ich und hier haben wir netterweise auch
direkt auf den preis mit 389 euro ist
die frage wann wird das gekauft 189 euro
und wie ist dann auch immer die
nachfrage danach ich guck mal kurz ob es
im internet immer noch für den gleichen
preis gibt also ich glaube für diese uhr
bekommt man nirgendwo 189 euro deswegen
ist sie vermutlich auch in diesem paket
gelandet aber gut hier wird die für 53
euro verkauft deswegen stellen wir die
mal schnell zur seite und greifen wieder
rein weil meine größte hoffnung habe ich
hier in edel zeit
das sieht eigentlich am hochwertigsten
aus auf den ersten blick und ich glaube
da ist auch eine uhr drin ja schrecklich
alter ich schwöre so was würde ich
niemals tragen
ich würde es auch nicht verschenken das
ist so eine uhr die hat man so haben so
die mädels in der zweiten klasse
getragen edel alter ist das eine
hässliche uhr sorry ist nur meine
meinung aber könnt ihr würdet ihr sowas
tragen könnt ihr gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
hinten steht natürlich drauf designed in
bavaria aha hier haben wir jedoch wird
zwischen 34 eur 90 und 99 euro gehandelt
ich wäre scheiße ich hab was steht da
auch im preis sind hier steht natürlich
99 euro drin das teuerste aber ich
glaube
die werde ich nicht los für mehr als 30
euro verständlicherweise also dass bis
jetzt auf jeden fall das hässlichste
hier drin
ihr könnt hier und da mal den
gesamtpreis sehen oder am ende wird er
auch noch mal eingeblendet wenn ich alle
sachen los bekommen sollte hat sich
bestimmt dann leicht gelohnt aber ich
habe es mir irgendwie kassel vorgestellt
also die 1000 euro da drin war ein
bisschen übertrieben hier haben wir noch
die weltbekannte marke docs.com ja hier
haben wir einige ringe guck mal 12 und
dann noch den dritten hier das ist so
ein klassischer ehering wenn man
heiratet möchte meine frau werden
hiermit b54 kristall für 950 euro 90
hier steht das preisschild auf jeden
fall noch dran und hier auch 49.90 muss
ich auch mal gleich im internet gucken
ob sie denn wirklich noch so viel wert
sind aber gut musst halt nur ein blöden
finden das kauft trotzdem muss ich sagen
diesen ring finde ich eigentlich für
mädels ganz schön also den könnte ich
mir bei marie gut vorstellen den behalte
ich einfach mal und obwohl was sagt ihr
vielleicht doch ein bisschen ein
bisschen zu hoch da hier oben drauf der
kristall ich muss aber sagen was mein
geschmack angeht ist das dingen
eigentlich ganz neues und dann haben wir
hier noch eine letzte sache drin
das ist eine kette und noch alter das
kann ich mir immer hier sind immer
preise darauf wieder 119 euro und 59
euro 90 leute so sieht die kette aus ihr
könnt es dann nochmal sehen 119 euro ich
weiß nicht also da kenne ich mich leider
zu wenig aus was schmutz angeht ob das
auflassen gerechtfertigter preis ist ich
muss einmal sagen an sich die qualität
geht auf jeden fall klar das ist eine
typische kette wie sie meine mama oben
rum liegen hat oder was ist dann kenia
ich finde hier gar nichts diese kette
yamaha die haben wir so 113 euro ein
geil ja das ist doch das thema safer
systems ungefähr nicht ganz scheiße
nicht ganz ich muss aber sagen bei
dieser kette glaube ich dass man dafür
110 120 euro verlangen kann
bei allem anderen bin ich mir halt
ziemlich unsicher trotzdem finde ich
diesen ring sehr schön und damit mache
ich meiner freundin marie auf jeden fall
bald ein heiratsantrag wenn dieses video
5006 bekommt und dann werde ich das film
und auf twitter hochladen baltic ist
einfach eine geile den gesamtpreis werde
ich euch jetzt mal eben noch errechnen
und hier ein sender der basiert auf den
günstigsten preisen wie im internet
gefunden habe und einige der sachen
verscherbele ich dann wie immer auf
lucky longhi punkte haben wir ja auch
schon länger jetzt keine werbung für
mehr gemacht deswegen checkt es auf
jeden fall sehr gern mal ab dass leute
was neues ich hoffe ja trotzdem ein
bisschen spaß beim zuschauen wir sehen
uns am sonntag spätestens wieder gibt's
neues video und bis dahin bleibt frisch
leute mach's gut abonniert sehr gerne
kanal haut rein